who's in your top five nelson rodriguez
jr just asked who's your top five if you
were to name to top five and uh you know
the greatest of all time who would you
have on that list ah i think the number
one for me is royce gracie because uh
of course if you put him in the octagon
right now he would have you would not
have do so well because sport have
changed but for his time i think for me
was the greatest of all time things that
you have done will never be done again i
mean maybe not of my living
i think you can put uh jimmy demetrius
johnson
you can put
mark coleman
probably
can put uh john jones of course anderson
silva these guys um
yeah mark coleman yeah yeah i think so
yeah i used to love them when he won the
the pride grand prix at the time yeah
japan it was so he was the best of the
best the natural follow-up to that is
because if you it's a remove your ego
from the situation right gsp everyone
would put you in their top five
everybody do you feel uncomfortable
putting yourself on that list no no no i
i i understand i i'm in the the list but
the
the greatest of all time it depends it
varies it's a very subjective thing
the thing is
in a sport like fighting is very
subjective who's better ali or
or tyson who's better you know what i
mean
in fighting we cannot measure
performance however if i ask you who's
the fastest printer you're gonna have to
tell me that it is usain bolt there's no
choice right you know why because we can
measure same thing in lifting uh the
sport that you have an instrument of
measure you have to go with the result
it's written and fighting is different
and we
we often feel sometimes that the
fighters of the past are better than the
one today very often
but i think it's illogical to think that
way and as hard and painful it is for me
because i retire
i believe
the fighters of today are better than
the one of yesterday but the fighter of
tomorrow and of the future will be even
better so the real goat is not even born
yet and it's not because the guys are
better it's because they are standing on
shoulders of giant they
benefit they have a head start because
they they learn from their predecessor
the technology the this stuff we just
talked about how you can learn from a
cell phone nowadays it's crazy i can
learn from with a cell phone jiu-jitsu
moves i couldn't do that back in a day i
had to go to from montreal to drive to
new york to learn these these skills you
know what i mean so things are different
so if i would take royce gracie and put
him putting him
today with the technology the knowledge
that he would benefit maybe would be
just as good or maybe better than
anybody
here in the in the present day you know
but there is no way to find out so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you